In the last quiz, Athena at first, had a two hour window of time in which she
knew the train would leave the mountain view station. Niko also told her it was
sometime between 4 p.m. and 6 p.m. That was a pretty big window. Then, with
more information from the train schedule, she narrowed down that window to this
tiny little yellow one, right here. Between just before 5 and just around 5:15.
The schedule then, is going to help her guess a lot better when the train's
going to leave. And we can imagine that if she had even more information about
the trains travel from Sunnyvale to Palo Alto, she could narrow down this
window even more. We can use this same method of starting zoomed out. And then,
zooming in, closer and closer, to help estimate the location of zeros that
don't occur at fractional or rational values of x. These are irrational zeros.
So, here on the graph, for example, you can see that y is negative down here.
But it's positive up here. We know that somewhere in this general region,
there's a point where y equals 0. We can find that exact point by zooming in
closer and closer.